We've looked at how routes
pair with templates and
what dynamic segments are in a route.
Let's take what we've learned and
start building out our app.
Wait a minute!
Remember, we don't want
to create routes and
template files by hands,
we're too lazy for that.
We'll use Ember CLI to create
everything for us instead.
Let's generate a route that will handle
things when the URL is slash menu.
So we'll use Ember's generate command,
but
remember that generate
has an alias of just g.
So I'll use that since it's shorter,
and we want to generate a route.
And we want that route
to match the URL menu.
This commanded a number of things for
us.
We'll skip these first two for
a second and come back to them.
Notice that the generate command we
just ran modified the router file and
added this line here.
This menu route we'll call
the menu.js route file and
then load the menu.jshbs template.
It also created a file for testing.
This is why Ember CLI is so
incredibly awesome.
It did all this force
with just one command.
So the generate command added
just this line to the router.
This menu route, loads the menu routes
file, then it loads the menu template.
We'll come back and look at these files
in detail soon, but first let's add some
content to the template file so
we can see something in the browser.
I've added this HTML here
with headings and images for
a few menu items, I've also included
the image files and a bit of CSS.
Back in the browser,
we don't really see anything.
Hm, when working with routes and
templates,
make sure you're actually
loading the correct route.
Adding menu shows us the template.
Awesome.